et darchy très fort pourquoi il a cette
promesse politique est très rare en
politique forte seul giscard il ya 50
ans avait la même c'est d'être le plus
jeune le plus expérimenté
[Musique]
près de 180 mille cas positifs en 24
heures en france jamais si le pays
n'avait connu de tels chiffres depuis le
début de la pandémie il ya deux ans une
propagation fulgurante des cas en raison
du variant omicron record de cas
également positif au portugal et en
grèce en finlande le gouvernement décide
de fermer ses frontières aux étrangers
non vaccinés en belgique et la justice
suspend la fermeture des salles de
spectacles a décidé par le gouvernement
pour tenter d'endiguer l'épidémie
[Musique]
est le niveau toujours dans l'impasse ir
le président michel aoun a appelé à
mettre fin à la paralysie
meetic dans le pays en crise il a
également profité pour implicitement
accusé le hezbollah de bloquer les
rayons du gouvernement le premier
ministre affirme aujourd'hui toujours
négocié avec le fonds monétaire
international importante et du tout
prouvé une solution ici est la fin du
mois de février
[Musique]
les nouvelles rencontres le 10 janvier
prochain à genève entre émissaires
russes et américains le but de cette
réunion ton et trouver des solutions à
la crise ukrainienne mais aussi
d'évoquer le contrôle de l'armement
nucléaire notre réunion entre la russie
les membres de l'otan pourraient aussi
avoir lieu dans la foulée le dos janvier
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
près de 180 mille cas positifs sur les
dernières 24 heures en france s est
clairement la première fois que le pays
connaît de tels chiffres depuis
l'apparition du virus sur le sol
français il y à presque deux ans
maintenant elle le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a demandé
aujourd'hui aux préfets de prendre des
mesures pour tenter d'éviter les
rassemblements et imposer le port du
masque dans les centres villes notamment
pour la nuit du nouvel an l jean castex
a demandé de son côté aux mairies de
renoncer à toute festivité jean michel
blanc coeur à lui s'est dévoilé un
nouveau protocole sanitaire pour la
rentrée dans les écoles
et des annonces qui s'ajoutent à celles
faites hier par jean castex et qui ont
provoqué de vives critiques au sein de
l'opposition a notamment autour du pass
vaccinale qui sera étudié à dès demain à
l'assemblée à leur rassemblement
national demande tout bonnement à de
leur crèche de se passe
les français notamment les jeunes et les
seniors ont été floués on leur a promis
un retour à la vie normale avec le
vaccin aujourd'hui je sous la menace
permanente de nouvelles restrictions il
est temps de s'engager vers un retour à
la vie normale je salue les annonces
équilibré de jean castex évolution vers
le pass vaccinale que j'appelais de mes
voeux et renforcement des sanctions pour
usage de faux pas sanitaire comportement
scandaleux et lourdes conséquences
redoublant d'efforts pour accélérer la
troisième dose sanctions interdictions
obligations mais toujours pas de moyens
et de stratégie pour tester notamment à
l'école de fric pour l'hôpital
d'exigence de lever des brevets seul
moyen d'éviter les nouveaux variants
bref ce gouvernement est nul il vaudrait
mieux le confiner faute d'avoir anticipé
organisé quoi que ce soit depuis des
mois cinq mille 900 lits d'hôpitaux
fermer en 2020 abandon de fait de
l'organisation du traçage isolement
l'exécutif en est réduit à commenter la
vague virale sans cohérence et en
affaiblissant en prime l'état de droit
et alors que les hôpitaux de france sont
de plus en plus débordés ont ces fêtes
de fin d'année pour arnaud chiche
anesthésie serre et animateur fondateur
du collectif santé en danger le coc
ville n'est pas responsable de l'état
actuel de l'hôpital
est ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
ces pâles covit qui est responsable de
l'état de l'hôpital ce n'est pas le co
lead ça c'est une fumisterie de
l'exécutif c'est l'hôpital est en grande
souffrance depuis des années mais la
pandémie qu'ovide c'est un effet de
lumière comme sur une scène avec des
projecteurs et ils ne font rien ils
disent qu'ils ont fait le ségur de la
santé mais ça ne suffit pas moi ce que
je ressens surtout depuis cette
cette conférence de presse c'est qu'on
est en campagne électorale
ils veulent se fâcher avec personne
assurément il se fâche avec les
soignants corbijn la politique de primes
on en a marre on l'a déjà dit depuis
deux ans la politique de rustines on en
a marre on veut un vrai plan santé mais
ça les français et ils vont le
comprendre quand même vous rendez compte
100 euros de prime comme ça a lâché
enfin cécile ces jeux je ne trouve pas
si gens là très sérieux et le
télétravail également de nouveau
obligatoire dans les entreprises
françaises dès la rentrée fait la
ministre du travail elisabeth bornes
elle a reçu je suis aujourd'hui les
syndicats et le patronat pour en
discuter l'idée d'un pass sanitaires
dans les entreprises est également
envisagée écoutez justement benjamin
hama hari les porte parole cgt du val de
marne je suis très interrogatif sur la
cohérence de l'ensemble au dossier
l'ensemble de ces mesures on a vraiment
l'impression qu'ils naviguent à vue le
télétravail compte il est possible
effectivement est une mesure
intéressante on rappelle que pour autant
d'ailleurs la cgt soit justement pouvoir
cadrer le télétravail que soit ce soit
pas simplement du travail à la maison au
laissant effectivement finalement les
patrons organisé ça comme il le souhaite
que ça puisse accompagner vu que ça a
été largement généralisée pendant un
temps et que là on n'y reviendrai que ce
soit effectivement assorties de
dispositions contraignantes pour les
employeurs et là dessus eh bien on n'est
pas souhaitée par le gouvernement
et qu'en est il du traitement contre le
kobe voilà un débat qui revient
régulièrement sur la table alors que la
pilule du laboratoire pfizer a été
autorisé aux états unis est de son côté
à l'agencé européenne du médicament a
validé cinq traitements le point
justement avec grâce d'ailleurs
actuellement lorsque l'on se retrouve à
l'hôpital pour cause de kovy de 19 10 et
vers les seuls traitements proposés sont
les corticoïdes et l'oxygénothérapie
et pourtant en octobre 2020 le monde
s'est arrêté sur le traitement magique
dont aurait bénéficié donald trump en
avant première mais de quoi s'agit-il un
traitement à base d'anticorps
monoclonaux c'est à dire de super
anticorps sélectionnés parmi les plus
efficaces collectés dans le sérum de
personnes guéries puis cloner des
traitements efficaces sur les quatre
variants reconnu l'alfa découvert en
angleterre le bêta en afrique du sud le
gamma au japon le delta découvert en
inde mais pour le nouveau venu omicron
ces traitements ne serait pas efficace
pourquoi les mutations qui ont abouti au
micro elle l'aurait rendu plus
transmissible et lui aurait permis
d'infecter plus fortement les organismes
la nouvelle souche résisterez à la
barrière de l'immunité aussi bien après
une infection qu'après une vaccination
avec une cinquantaine de mutation
omicron semble difficile à neutraliser
mais tous ne serez pas perdu après des
tests sur différents anticorps
monoclonaux certains conservent une part
de leur efficacité le premier est le xix
vu dit dont la baisse d'efficacité et
modéré il est utilisé dans le traitement
précoce des patients infectés ayant des
facteurs à risque de développer une
forme grave il a été commandé par
l'union européenne et devrait arriver
dans les hôpitaux en janvier le sel
trion nouvellement validé par l' agence
européenne du médicament n'est pas
encore diffusée en france le kotel
thérapeutique il vu celle d'astrazeneca
conserverait une activité neutralisante
significative malgré une baisse
d'activité plus importantes utilisées en
préventif il al'avantage d'être
administrée par une simple piqûre et
seulement tous les six mois et en ce qui
concerne celui qui semble le plus
efficace actuellement le pacs le vide de
pfizer son efficacité al'avantage de ne
pas dépendre des variants passées ou à
venir ce qui lui permettrait de lutter
activement contre mikron autorisé par l'
agence européenne du médicament
il sera disponible dès février prochain
et le monde donc face à la menace du
variant mikron pour la contrer les pays
temps de s'organiser avec souvent est la
mise en place de nouvelles mesures de
restriction c'est le cas en allemagne
des manifestations ont été organisées
pour protester contre la décision du
gouvernement
c'est le cas à bautzen dans l'est du
pays où des affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre ont
fait au moins 10 blessés côté policier
important avec la mise en place de cette
mesure restrictive berlin a déjà divisé
par deux son taux d'incidence en trois
semaines et veut encore aller plus loin
clément le court
magdebourg
potsdam
munich les manifestations contre les
nouvelles restrictions se multiplient
actuellement en allemagne car pour
lutter contre la propagation du virus le
gouvernement a décidé de resserrer la
vis en cette fin d'année
limitation des rassemblements privé à 10
personnes vaccinées seulement 2 pour les
non vaccinés les discothèques seront
quant à elles fermées et l'ensemble des
compétitions sportives se dérouleront à
huis clos à berlin théâtre régulier de
manifestations anti restriction ou anti
vaccination certains sont plutôt
favorables à ces nouvelles mesures
je trouve que les dispositions prises
ont du sens et je m'y adapte je trouve
que cela fonctionne bien je ne perçois
pas de restriction majeure dans ma vie
privée pour ainsi dire
les règles sont très différentes il
serait préférable qu'elle soit uniforme
pour tous les états allemands je suis
très favorable aux restrictions pas de
problème à continuer comme ça si ces
nouvelles restrictions semble convenir à
certains berlinois elle déplaise aux
conseils scientifiques allemands qui les
jugent insuffisantes
à cause du variant omicron il faut
s'attendre à une vague d'infections
d'une dynamique jamais vu auparavant
la tendance est claire avec des
contaminations qui double tous les trois
jours
le nouveau variant omicron pourrait
devenir la majorité des cas d'infection
en allemagne en une deux ou au plus tard
trois semaines
une nouvelle réunion est d'ores et déjà
prévue le 7 janvier prochain entre la
rolls et les länder pour faire un point
sur la situation épidémique
est du côté des pays les plus pauvres la
livraison des vaccins posent question
interviewé aujourd'hui par rt
internationale la porte parole de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
margaret harris s'est exprimé sur le
sujet
au tout début de cette pandémie tous les
pays du monde se sont réunis et on dit
oui nous devons vacciner le monde entier
en même temps malheureusement lorsque
les vaccins sont devenus disponibles
l'intérêt égoïste ou je ne sais quoi
d'autre a prévalu et tous les contrats
ont été achetés par les pays les plus
riches en ressources laissant les pays
qui sont moins puissants et ont moins de
ressources au bout de la file d'attenté
mais nous avons mis en place un système
baptisé kovacs pour garantir que les
vaccins soient fournis à tout le monde
pas de distinction pauvres et riches
pour tout autour de la planète et nous
avons pu livrer des vaccins dans des
pays pauvres en ressources grâce à ce
système mais cela n'a pas été aussi
efficace que nous le voulions parce que
nous ne pouvions tout simplement pas
obtenir toutes les 12 mais la bonne
nouvelle est que ce chiffre a vraiment
augmenté dans le cadre de la dernière
campagne nous avons réussi à livrer huit
cent mille doses et maintenant c'est en
milliards qui a été distribuée dans le
monde entier donc ce n'est pas autant
que nous aimerions mais nous augmentons
réellement la quantité de vaccins
disponibles dans le reste du monde et
nous voulons continuer à accroître cela
le niveau toujours dans l'impasse face à
la paralysie politique le président
libanais michel aoun appelle un dialogue
national urgent une crise politique qui
aggravent un peu les difficultés
économiques du pays les précisions avec
cyrielle bref
deux hommes pour un même discours à
quelques heures d'intervalle le
président libanais michel aoun et son
premier ministre nagib mikati se sont
exprimées concernant la paralysie
politique qui sévit dans le pays depuis
quelques mois le chef de l'état exhorte
le gouvernement à se réunir au plus vite
la perturbation délibéré systématique et
injustifiées de l'état doit cesser cela
conduit au démantèlement des
institutions et à la dissolution de
l'état
la désorganisation du gouvernement est
responsable de la paralysie de
l'administration de l'état alors que les
employés attendent leurs droits les
hôpitaux leurs salaires et les patients
leur traitement
je vais continuer à mes forces et de
faire en sorte que le gouvernement se
réunit ce d'autant plus qu'il y à des
questions qui sont essentielles pour que
le conseil se réunissent notamment le
budget de l'état le budget de l'état a
été épuisé il doit passer par le
gouvernement car c'est l'une des étapes
de notre réforme le premier ministre
libanais espèrent un accord avec le
fonds monétaire international d'ici à la
fin du mois de février un accord plus
que nécessaire pour le liban englué dans
une crise économique depuis l'explosion
du port de beyrouth en août 2020 le plan
de relance économique est au point mort
certains ministres pro hezbollah refuse
de participer aux réunions ils exigent
le retrait du juge principal chargé de
l'enquêté sur l'explosion du port de
beyrouth qu'ils accusent de partialité
depuis le début de la crise la livre
libanaise a perdu 90% de sa valeur et
plus de 80% des libanais vivant en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté etc leur
cause que le secrétaire général de l'onu
antonio guterres s a plaidé la semaine
dernière en visite à beyrouth il a
appelé les politiques du pays à se
concentrer sur leurs besoins
j'ai exhorté les dirigeants politiques
du liban à mettre en oeuvre des réformes
qui répondent aux demandes du peuple
libanais pour plus de bien-être de
responsabilité de protection et de
transparence afin de restaurer l'espoir
d'un avenir meilleur
un espoir qui semble pourtant bien
lointain pour le liban lors d'un
discours télévisé vendredi dernier le
président michel aoun a déclaré que le
pays aurait besoin de six à sept ans
pour sortir de la crise
et la situation au liban n'en parle
justement tout de suite avec notre grand
reporter régis fermier
elles régissent bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors régis
qu'en est il en ce moment même de la
situation politique au liban alors que
le gouvernement ne s'est plus réuni
depuis le 12 octobre dernier
oui c'est une situation critique mais
j'ai envie de dire c'est un peu une
fatalité au liban ces situations où il
ya un blocage institutionnel uni à un
blocage politique un blocage des
institutions pendant c'est pas la
première fois d'ailleurs là pour le coup
c'est le premier ministre et le
président qui s'expriment faut pas
oublier qu'il ya quelques années le
liban était resté sans gouvernement
pendant plus de quatre ans donc il ya
toujours ce problème le la différence
avec ya quelques années c'est que
aujourd'hui le liban malheureusement ne
peut plus calmes ne peut plus se
permettre de perdre du temps ça a été
donc mentionné dans le reportage la
dévaluation de la livre les problèmes
migratoires les problèmes comment
institutionnels conçu consubstantiel
finalement que peu de commandes de cette
répartition confessionnelle des comme on
veut des instances dirigeantes au liban
font que aujourd'hui la situation est
complètement bloquée et que le liban
donc est dans une crise majeure une
crise majeure dont il ne peut sortir
finalement sans l'aide internationale et
l'aide du fmi et pour le moment cette
aide elle est conditionnée à un certain
nombre de choses alors ce qui a été
intéressant quand même aujourd'hui dans
le discours de michel aoun c'est que le
président pour la première fois à
critiquer son allié le hezbollah qui l'a
accusé de faire de l'obstruction
systématique et injustifiée il a dit que
cette obstruction systématique
injustifiée mené au démantèlement
institutionnels et à la dissolution de
l'êta dont il a pris les devants d'une
certaine façon n'hésitant pas à
critiquer le hesbollah également gibran
bassil l'a fait aussi donc la cia il ya
un différé ya eu un différend entre
comment donc bassil son parti et le
hezbollah sur des questions justement de
deux des prochaines élections alors les
il est là il y aura des élections qui
vont se tenir le 15 mai mais il faut
qu'il y ait un éclaircissement il faut
que le liban puisse enfin aboutir à
quelque chose
michel aoun ce soir avait des allures de
chef d'état mais d'un chef d'état qui
qui sonne l'alarmé j'ai envie de dire
presque qui sonne le tocsin alors le
premier ministre l'a annoncé cet après
midi les discussions avec le fmi sont
toujours en cours et le premier ministre
libanais justement elle qui espère une
issue favorable avant la fin du mois de
janvier
que pensez-vous du délai est ce qu'une
issue favorable justement est possible
avant la fin du mois de janvier
ça paraît très illusoire les choses sont
on le voit très compliqué là là là là
comment le le grippage de la société
libanaise et était est énorme
elle est toujours dans le fait que le
liban à 2 par sa répartition
confessionnelle héritée de la guerre
civile a du mal à évoluer vers une
nation jeux d'hiver comment qui
fonctionne un petit peu dans lequel on
oublie justement ces différences la lune
des le liban je dirais a touché le fond
avec cette fameuse explosion à nos
milieux de beyrouth en août 2000 2020 et
on s'aperçoit que même pour l'anc est
sur les causes de cette explosion et
bien il y a
décommandé divergences donc on n'arrive
pas à comment arraisonné en tant que
nation on n'arrive pas à raisonner en
tant que peuple et pourtant c'est vers
ça que le liban s'il veut retrouver la
prospérité qu'il a eu jadis eh bien il
devra forcément passer par des réformes
institutionnelles c'est ce vers quoi
quand michel aoun a appelé aujourd'hui
il semble en fait en tout cas qu'on est
dans un blocage mais il y a toujours de
l'espoir il faudra forcément trouver une
solution vous le disiez tout à l'heure
régis le sommier est le président michel
aoun a accusé implicitement le hesbollah
de bloquer les réunions du du
gouvernement
tall issue pour avec avec le hezbollah
de la part du gouvernement
écoutez le hezbollah était l'alliée
principale de michel aoun ccc son
support c'est vrai que le hezbollah et
comment est à la fois à un acteur
puissant c'est le l'acteur le plus
puissant c'est celui parmi les
différents comment je dirais oui comment
depuis qu'on appelle la résistance qui a
fait ses lettres de noblesse justement
en s'opposant à israël quand celui ci
occupe et le liban sud et de cette
renommée le hezbollah a gagné une part
dans la société o comment au liban vous
allez 27% de chiites et le hezbollah et
c'est l'autre partie à mal un carnet
représente c'est chic donc qu'il est
impossible de les sortir de l'équation
mais il y a toujours ces affrontements
qui existent justement entre et de sa
critique majeure du rôle du hezbollah de
la question de sa pop la possession des
armes et du fait que ça reste une milice
sur armée parallèle à l'armée libanaise
et que tout ça est extrêmement compliqué
extrêmement il est il est aujourd'hui
toujours extrêmement difficiles au liban
de sortir du triste confessionnelles
dans lequel cette société est engluée
merci beaucoup régis le sommier d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur arte france
rappelle et que vous êtes grand reporter
pour arte france merci beaucoup
émissaires américains et russes de
nouveau autour de la table de
négociation le 10 janvier prochain à
genève le but tenté d'évoquer de trouver
des solutions quant aux tensions à la
frontière ukrainienne est les deux
puissances évoqueront également les
questions du contrôle de l'armement
nucléaire et hier le patron de l'otan a
également invité la russie à discuter le
12 janvier prochain elle les précisions
de notre correspondante à moscou prague
hoffman
l'avenir des pourparlers entre la russie
et l'alliance atlantique reste incertain
pas de date définitive concernant des
discussions entre la russie et le temps
au sujet des garanties de sécurité
mutuelle a ainsi déclaré le vice
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï riabkov plutôt des informations
avaient filtré sur une éventuelle
rencontre russie etats unis le 10
janvier et russie otan le 12 janvier
moscou attend encore des confirmations
de la part de le temps aux sujets de
composition de la délégation et insiste
également sur le fait que l'agenda ne
devienne pas je cite une abstraction
mais se concentre sur les propositions
russes de sécurité mutuelle je vous
propose d'écouter il est extrêmement
important pour nous de recevoir la
confirmation de la part de l'otan que
des militaires de haut rang seront
inclus dans ces délégations lors de
l'événement du 12 janvier à bruxelles
nous nous y rendons dans un format
interministériel et notre ministère de
la défense sera représenté à un niveau
très élevé et il est important pour nous
que les militaires est une conversation
professionnels moscou envisage
différentes manières de répondre aux
intimidations de le temps mais espère
passer par la voie diplomatique avait
déclaré dimanche vladimir poutine des
points essentiels pour éviter le
déploiement de l'otan vers l'est ainsi
qu'un engagement de l'alliance
atlantique à ne pas construire de bases
militaires dans des états de l'ex-bloc
soviétique comme en ukraine
ou 10 10 maillots ministre italien des
affaires étrangères est à carthage pour
une visite de travail avec son homologue
tunisien à l'occasion pour les deux pays
de parfaire les contours de leur
coopération notamment en matière de
gestion de l'immigration le point à
tunis avec notre correspondant bassam
shellys
luigi maillot en visite officielle après
l annonce faite le 10 décembre dernier
par l'ambassadeur italien en tunisie
lorenzo fanara à l'occasion pour les
deux pays de faire le point sur des
dossiers brûlants tels que la migration
la question libyenne le dossier des
déchets italiens ou encore le soutien de
rome auprès de l'union européenne dans
la sphère de la prolongation du gel des
fonds tunisiens en europe une visite
marathon pour le chef de la diplomatie
italienne dans un contexte de crise
migratoire entre les deux rives porte
d'entrée en europe l'italie est de plus
en plus pointés du doigt quant à sa
gestion et au traitement qu'elle réserve
aux migrants qui arrivent dans ces
centres de détention en marge de la
visite de luigi et di maio de nombreuses
associations de défense des droits
humains ont tenu ce matin au coeur de la
capitale une conférence de presse
objectif alerter les autorités et
l'opinion publique sur les circonstances
des décès de plusieurs jeunes tunisiens
dans ces centres italien le dernier en
date wissem abdellatif un jeune homme de
26 ans décédé dans des circonstances que
sa famille qualifient de douteuse à
l'hôpital sant camillo de rome après son
arrivée en sicile début octobre pour ses
proches qui attendent toujours le
rapatriement de sa dépouille et les
membres d'avocats sans frontières les
circonstances ayant entraîné sa mort
restent à clarifier je vous propose
d'écouter à ce sujet zaineb rookie
membres d'avocats sans frontières on
veut saisir cette occasion pour
justement mettre en lumière la les
circonstances
douteuses de la mort de 800 leurs actifs
mais aussi d'autres
d'autres d'autres tunisiens qui sont
morts dans des conditions assez opaque
pour le moment la vie la mort de visser
aime bien tout petit peu pour pour
mettre en lumière ces cds c'est là mais
aussi sur les circonstances de détention
administrative qui ont lieu dans les
centres de rétention en italie
et toutes ces conventions bilatérales
que la tunisie sin depuis des années qui
viennent un peu
apporté une discrimination envers les
tunisiens quant à leur rapatriement qui
vient un peu entravé leur droit d'asile
on essaie un peu de faire de collecter
des données par rapport par rapport aux
tunisiens qui sont rapatriés de d'italie
on essaye d'avoir des échanges avec eux
qui nous rapportent qu'ils n'ont aucun
aucune conscience de leurs droits ils
savent pas s'ils sont en mesure de
demander la protection internationale
dans quelles conditions un dossier qui
devrait être au coeur des discussions
entre les deux ministres des affaires
étrangères alors que le nombre de jeunes
tunisiens risquant leur vie pour
rejoindre les côtes européennes de
manière illégale est en constante
augmentation selon le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés des tunisiens ont
représenté en 2021 25 % des arrivées
illégale en italie sont onze mille
quarante deux personnes contre 20% en
2020 et avant de refermer ce journal la
russie a réussi le lancement de sa fusée
sa nouvelle fusée de nouvelle génération
en gare à au moment où moscou cherche à
moderniser sa flotte spatiale les
responsables de l'opération qualifiée de
véritable succès il s'agit du troisième
lancement test depuis 2014 d'une fusée
dit en gare à elle remplacera les
anciens danseurs datant des années 60
elle engagera est aussi et moins
polluante propulsé par un mélange de
kérosène et d'oxygène liquide un succès
pour ce troisième lancement russe je
vous laisse ce quelques secondes avec
ses magnifiques images
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité elle dans un peu plus de
trente minutes reste avec nous sur arte
france à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
depuis plus d'un an le président bak
road était convaincu que le retrait
annonce la chancelière allemande le
positionnerait comme le chef naturel
d'une europe à laquelle ils imposeraient
s'est vu la réalité allemande